how do I get sin is the Institute of
arson ideas unique festival combining
days full of talks and debates in
philosophy politics arts and science
with evenings full of music and dance
get your tickets for the world's largest
musical philosophy first of all how that
I guess in Tamil is it we have a strong
sense of their own identity or their own
responsibility in a global community I'm
going to UM pass the question - yes Minh
yeah I think the UM the - the first
point about the nation-state I find very
fascinating because who gets to
ultimately for me it's about who gets to
decide who is part of the nation right I
was born one place bred somewhere else
lives somewhere else where where do I
belong exactly everyone who speaks to me
about this concept of a nation and must
belonging to a nation in the allegiance
to nation has the luxury of being born
into a particular place that has looked
after them or not but they feel that
they are secure in right and there is no
question about that and there are there
is a diaspora around the world who
doesn't have that luxury and anyone who
says that the world is borderless has
the right passport right the border the
world is not borderless if you've got a
Sudanese passport
let me tell you right my cousin's
couldn't even visit me in Australia
because it was deemed some sort of risk
or they would not want to return so the
the concept of a nation-state I think
needs to be challenged or interrogated
but my I guess the other point is that
we have created this binary that there
must be or a false dichotomy I would
argue that there must be like an
us-and-them
or if I am part of a nation then I must
think this way about and I think yes
maybe historically that has existed but
we also can evolve democracy was
something that a group of people decided
you know what we want to change the way
that we do business here so let's design
a better system and I think our
challenge is to say there's a and you
may know more of this than I do but it's
a really interesting when you look at
post-colonial nations and the leaders of
post-colonial nations when they've come
up they want to sort of fight for
independence etc etc then they get to
positions of power and they treat others
in the exact same way that they were
treated because we have
real alternative perhaps models of power
we actually historically have struggled
so I think the challenges all right
we're all evolved beings we have to
create new models of organizing all bets
on models or re encourage the habit of
democracy or other forms of government
that allow us to organize in ways that
are not about a full stuck on me get
your tickets for the world's largest
music and philosophy festival how the
light gets in dog